[Music]  [Applause]  i would [ __ ] that girl if she was my  sister i would let that girl give me  [ __ ] aids  see the wolf we handle this yes  jordan this is my friend naomi hi naomi  nice to meet you naomi nice to meet you  nice to meet you we've got an awesome  place here  i don't think i've ever been in a house  this big before oh really yeah beautiful  beach out there thank you larry holly's  work  hi brad nice to meet you  name's blair right yeah you like the jet  skiing i've never done it before you've  never jet ski in your life no i've never  never been on a jet ski no how many  times you're gonna ask her she's never  been on a jet ski  i don't know i might ask her a couple  more times  you know sure  hi i'm hildy nice to meet you hi jordan  teresa need your help yeah i'll be in a  couple minutes just tell him i'll be  honest  why don't you tell your wife that i  might do that but i'm having a  conversation  you like